going with the ideas that you know since
we're combating racism or combating
classism and gentrification and any kind
of discrimination and oppression that
exists as much in New York and every
other major city in America as it does
in New Orleans it's just not quite as
obvious to see so it doesn't really make
sense just to bring people to normal do
the work and come home and just sit
around waiting for the next trip to
happen so we have started to organize
and do work here I guess we consider
ourselves community organizers but our
community is high school students so we
don't feel that we're the ones who
necessarily need to be like out there in
the streets organizing residents to go
to meetings that we hold like NY dental
meetings that's not our purpose our job
is to do that in high schools and to
student groups or after-school programs
or churches or whatever and mobilize as
many students as possible to get
involved here and then but we have
partnered with a number of organizations
who do work within communities of New
York to organize residents and so we're
not reinventing the wheel where we're
adding another spoke or you know
whatever you want to however you want to
put that but um so we're working with
these different organizations in one
major way that we're doing work here is
we've started a community service and
internship program and so now when we do
presentations we speak about the trip we
encourage people to sign up for the
trips but we also say that they can sign
up and do the exact same stuff here in
New York City and you know what schools
where students have to complete
community service hours or do an
internship it's great because we attract
a whole bunch of students who may
otherwise have never cared to get
involved but you know they need they
have a requirement so they sign up but
you know will we get people who care all
over the place and you know our job is
they come to us and we are going to
start off with a forum where we discuss
the history of NY de ano similar to the
very first day in New Orleans and
discuss our history what we do why we're
doing this and then from there the
students will be placed with one of the
seven groups that we work with and every
week they'll go and do volunteering
which would be canvassing neighborhoods
helping to plan protests making phone
calls whatever that organization needs
at any given time and then once a month
we'll pull all the students together so
that we can have a big debrief type of a
thing and everybody can reflect on their
experiences with their organizations how
things are going and then
we would have workshops on student
leadership and talking about the history
of students within social movements so
that because a lot of the time I think
that we as students feel demoralized it
feel like we can't make a change the
same way we kind of felt at the
beginning when a lot of adults kind of
said all this is nice but you're not
really going to go anywhere but you know
the fact that we've created this is
already inspiration in itself to any
other student that we talk to because we
have created this with pretty much no
help from adults so which is a very nice
thing and it's inspiring thing to a lot
of students and you know the the program
is slowly starting to develop this year
is pretty much working on planting seeds
in different areas in different schools
so that next year it blows up and we
just have kids from all over the city
you know really working together on this
program just as much if not more than we
send people down some